when we worked out and I always sharp
doesn't matter I'm sorry simply I always
shout Jay doesn't like you cuz you know
he's not as comfortable in the skin is
me yeah big old dick yep I want everyone
to know he's got a dick movie in the
shower hey get to hoggy out and like
shut up shut up and have a talent I'll
rip the towel off like Halle learn and
slabs big hog alert cause the 1i learn I
think I've got a story before we had
Greenwood athletic club we're super nice
club but there's the hot tubs where I
like the older members hang out but they
face the shower yeah and I purposely and
you can shower other places i personally
showered there cuz i knew these old
dudes to be staring at j's grand hago so
and so we r sh and hago so mandago so
your Grandpa's oh so oh you got a real
piece grand hago Phelan called it it's
called a grand hog oh so it's called a
hog oh so holy SH ate his ship was here
and I go oh boy here we go and he goes
what under stirring the Palio he was
violent well guys didn't you dick and he
goes who and he who knows I was and he
goes hold on it's all covered in hot
Chloe look singers god damn it and I go
just do your business man and we get out
of here please doing a go oh boy he was
well it they're mocking your dick I can
swing your dick and he goes hey he turns
I goes what the [ __ ] man we got issues
over here we got issues on there I go
hey woody can you beat up the for older
sold so we got like shake like if their
hearts beat any faster now gonna die
that hot tub they all give it like they
do a backbend oh my dog will stop like
dead game overs like shrimp in there
like radio diet anytime I go dude what
are you doing there just glancing at
your hog amigos [ __ ] that man we got
prom on like I you know what let's just
get out of here there was this girl in
college I won't say her name but those
of you that went to University of
Colorado won't choose an athlete
clapping along talking about he was so
fun she was so fun if she'd been Satan
issues into Satan lives in like I am hey
that's funny I thought she could be like
I'm a total racist maybe like well I'm
gonna text me but after that I'm
yeah yeah yeah you're looking do what
ever get she was so far when I say she
was religious she makes Tim Tebow look
like Johnny Manziel she was loose our
little boy it was a gtalk tin Bible plot
it really didn't make sense huh and you
can I mean you couldn't get close to
unless you know hot she's hot she's
trying not to do somehow she needs God
that she's wearing Jesus like chains
yeah but to know Jesus like girl you
need to [ __ ] relax right even Jesus
like too much right much I got them to
vote devoted followers Jimmu you could
ask too much jus good Act you not only
that by good act give your boy be shava
opening yeah now did she ever give you
an opening unimportant not even know she
she was a steel steel door oh my god not
get into that door did anybody get in
that door not that I know never everyone
tried and you didn't have I'm talking
you can have a shot what's he doing now
I don't know people i'm sure my friends
know I'd love to find out I bet it's not
good it's interesting to see what
happens to seven dollars in bank account
it just seems with 22 fanatics because
that's fanatical right you such a good
athlete too really oh well I love how
honest you are about everything it's
pretty liberating you know why you know
why do it what because if I don't do it
it basically it's this it's like you
know I don't want people to have
ammunition to hurt me Yeah Yeah Yeah
right so what all your might 8 mile
right what I do I just go everything get
it all out everything about me right
there's nothing that you can say to hurt
me like people on Twitter go you're not
funny you should quit doing comedy go
[ __ ] yourself right but because of the
bathroom ridiculousness I know but they
do say it you know but they say but
Chris Rock it's that freaking bro I
understand that it doesn't hurt me it
doesn't hurt me you're looking for a
response out of you all right and I
don't respond to it by Mike LeBron James
gets you suck it back yeah yeah anyone
in the world get that you suck Yeah
right I would want to find you you
[ __ ] suck at playing alright man cool
yeah but I think it helps to get
everything out there so that now
now I'm an open book and also like I'm
not proud of the things I've done in my
life but arm I've accepted it what are
you proud of I'm kind of a lot of things
yeah i think the things I'm proud of
Islam listen to me like for an
asian-american to spend eight years on
an American sketch show huge is never
been a great never done been dumped and
be great at it yeah it's never been done
before and I don't ever get credit for
we're Korean so chin he's a big deal
yeah like when I questions coming on
hello I know when I told you what I told
jr. come on Isaac oh well yeah I love by
Michael it's for sure relax and it's a
brad Pitt yeah yeah and he's like no but
for Koreans the big deal man I mean it
listen listen I mean a lot of koreans
like me and some don't but that's fine
but it's like I'm just saying what I
feel part of and it's like you know when
i'm from san diego my parents are
immigrants I have no connection
whatsoever with Hollywood of show
business I literally started from the
streets I was walking down pearl street
where the comedy store in La Jolla is
cowboy I saw a Help Wanted sign this is
we need dishwashers I was 23 years old I
knocked on the door during the day Fred
burns the manager at the time hired me
and I started doing open mics and that's
how I started to go from there to where
I am now yeah I look in the mirror ago
you know what it's like you I haven't
had a day job in 20 years really yeah I
always make a really good nut a year and
for me to do that being you know the way
I look at my ethnicity all that stuff is
really a miracle and I didn't quit
that's the main building american dream
son you got to take risks man we'll talk
again that makes me think of Jorge
Macedon there's other guys like that and
a part of a subset of my job is to make
people see that Cub Swanson is very
special or Jorge mantels very special
you know they don't always see that they
see the people that are marketed in a
certain way or that speak a certain way
or that look a certain way but that
moment in the fight I was going to wear
a chance uninsured today because it's a
in support of jail yeah cuz I [ __ ]
lot can meet you I loved you just on
here soon
alas I love that man he's a really
really good man he's him Joe and I other
guys have really helped me and been
supportive and liked what I did and said
hey how do we get you going other places
and that's been really kind of jails one
of those guys and I love Jail and that
moment in there and like say dan hardy
who's a good friend I admire him a lot
he was really hard on jail in that fight
did he say it was more scripted than a
Britney group but later and who no going
back at their house hear what he said
out there's really no I love doing to I
thought I love doing that note that
would you block that out there's no I
wasn't serious so here's the thing about
Twitter someone will respond to
something Dan or anybody you or anybody
wrote for rapper and when the moments in
time that you go through life you are
many different things sometimes you are
an [ __ ] yeah sometimes you are a nice
person sometimes you're kind and
sometimes you're just not thinking yeah
and yet somebody will look at that tweet
for reference I go dan said this man I
know what he really thinks behind you
yeah exactly yeah and then literally
managed systems so then later when he
was talking about it I saw a little clip
of it and he was like you know I thought
he was going to fight he was hard on him
and I get it and I realized in that
moment dan is different than me and you
and jail what you're describing to some
degree he's maybe never had that that
moment where his brain cells him out
yeah you know what I mean that because
people don't get it they're like you
know and Dan who's a genius he's because
he's one human being and his perspective
of the world he's never or never had it
to them up to the level that Jo may have
experienced it or that I've experienced
so that others we're in that moment you
want to win and you want to succeed and
you want so badly to do well and for
some reason the lizard part of your
brain [ __ ] sells you out yeah and
it's not like you're saying I don't want
to fight all I want to tap all I don't
want your [ __ ] brain cells you out in
that moment and there's no way to
prepare for that